ARE GETTING.
NOT RAPISTS.
>> Martha: WE DON'T KNOW THAT,
OF COURSE.
>> WE DO!
>> Martha: WE DON'T!
JORGE
>> Tucker: HAS NOT BEEN FORCED
TO REGISTER AS A FOREIGN AGENT.
HE ALSO WROTE THE BOOK,
"STRANGER," THE CHALLENGE OF
BEING LATINO IN THE TRUNK ERA.
JORGE, THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
THE FIRST       FIRST AND THE MS
THE FIRST       FIRST AND THE MT
THE FIRST       FIRST AND THE MI
THE FIRST       FIRST AND THE MP
THE FIRST       FIRST AND THE MR
THE FIRST       FIRST AND THE MA
THE FIRST       FIRST AND THE MT
QUESTION IS WHY SHOULD WE LET
THESE ASYLUM-SEEKERS, THESE
MIGRANTS INTO THE COUNTRY?
>> I THINK THE UNITED STATES IS
BEING HIGH
HOSTILE AND EVEN
AGGRESSIVE COUNTRY AGAINST
REFUGEES AND IMMIGRANTS.
WE HAVE A LONG HISTORY OF BEING
ACCEPTING OF IMMIGRANTS FROM
COUNTRIES WHERE THEY ARE FLEEING
VIOLENCE AND POVERTY AND LACK OF
DEMOCRACY.
I THINK THAT'S PRECISELY WHAT
THE UNITED STATES IS.
AT THE END, TUCKER, I THINK IT'S
A MATTER OF DECIDING WHAT KIND
OF COUNTRY DO WE WANT TO BE.
IT SEEMS AT THIS POINT THAT WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT A FEW HUNDRED
REFUGEES AND PUTTING IT IN
CONTEXT FROM THE 65 MILLION
REFUGEES THAT ARE AROUND THE
WORLD.
THE UNITED STATES EXCEPT AND
ONLY 84,000 IN 2016 AND THIS IS
GOING TO BE EVEN LESS.
IT'S A MATTER OF DECIDING WHAT
KIND OF COUNTRY DO WE WANT TO
BE.
>> Tucker: WE'VE ACCEPTED
ABOUT 13 MILLION REFUGEES,
ECONOMIC REFUGEES IN OUR COUNTRY
NOW ILLEGALLY.
BUT BACKUP FOR ONE SECOND.
YOU SAID THIS IS A HOSTILE,
DANGEROUS PLACE FOR REFUGEES?
WHY WOULD YOU WANT THEM TO COME
HERE IF UNITED STATES IS SO
DANGEROUS?
>> THAT IS MUCH, MUCH BETTER
THAN IF YOU ARE A FATHER IN
SAN PEDRO SULA AND YOU HAVE A
SUDDEN, THE SON WANTS TO BE
RECRUITED BY THE GANGS.
OR IF THEY WANT TO THREATEN YOUR
ONLY DAUGHTER, THEY WANT TO RAPE
HER, WHAT DO YOU WANT TO DO?
MAY BE THE ONLY OPTION IS TO
COME TO THE UNITED STATES --
B1 IT'S NOT THE >> Tucker:
I'M NOT THE CITIZEN OF ANY OTHER
COUNTRY.
I PLAN TO STAY.
YOU DON'T NEED TO CONVINCE ME
WHY PEOPLE WANT TO COME.
I UNDERSTAND WHY THEY WOULD.
BUT IN ORDER TO GET HERE, THEY
PASSED THROUGH MEXICO, WHICH IS
BY MANY MEASURES A RICH COUNTRY.
THE 15TH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD.
THERE ARE 30 MEXICAN -- IT'S GOT
A BIGGER ECONOMY THAN
SAUDI ARABIA.
THEY ARE PEOPLE SLEEPING IN THE
SLEEP IN TIJUANA.
GOVERNMENT HELP THEM?
>> FIRST OF THEM, THEY DO NOT
WANT TO STAY IN MEXICO.
THEY WANT TO COME TO THE
UNITED STATES FEARED SECOND OF
ALL, IF YOU ARE FLEEING
VIOLENCE, IF YOU ARE FLEEING
GANGS FROM HONDURAS AND
EL SALVADOR, WHY WOULD YOU WANT
TO GO TO MEXICO WHEN IN THE LAST
FIVE YEARS MORE THAN 100,000
PEOPLE WERE KILLED BY DRUG
VIOLENCE?
WOULD YOU STAY IN MEXICO?
OF COURSE NOT.
>> Tucker: NO!
I ACTUALLY PROBABLY WANT TO FLY
BUSINESS CLASS TO ZURICH AND FLY
TO THE ALPS.
I DON'T GET TO BECAUSE IT'S NOT
MY COUNTRY.
>> SO YOU WANT TO CLOSE THE
UNITED STATES?
THAT'S WHAT YOU WANT TO DO?
>> Tucker: YES.
I WANT TO REVERT TO WHAT WE WERE
NUMBER WHICH IS A COUNTRY OF
LAWS WHERE PEOPLE CAN COME HERE
BUT THEY DO SO LEGALLY.
WE HAVE OVER A MILLION PEOPLE
COME HERE EVERY YEAR LEGALLY.
THEY FILL OUT THE PAPERWORK,
THEY GET IN LINE FROM AROUND THE
WORLD.
I DON'T KNOW WHY THAT SYSTEM
DOESN'T WORK.
>> THEN THEY WANT TO COME HERE
ILLEGALLY.
THEY WANT TO COME HERE LEGALLY
THROUGH THE WAY IN TIJUANA, FOR
TURQUOISE DAYS, THEY HAVE NOT
BEEN ALLOWED TO TALK TO AN
AGENT.
>> Tucker: THEY ARE TRYING TO
BE HERE LEGALLY.
THEY ARE TRYING TO COME HERE AND
CLAIM ASYLUM WHICH IN EFFECT
MEANS A COURT DATE WILL BE SET
AND THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY
WILL NOT SHOW UP FOR COURT AND
THEY WILL BLEND IN WITH THE
OTHER 13 MILLION --
>> I MEAN, THAT'S NOT TRUE.
THEY ARE FLEEING VIOLENCE, THEY
ARE FLEEING GANGS --
B1 HOW DO YOU KNOW THAT?
WHAT DO YOU
>> Tucker: HOW DO YOU KNOW
THAT?
>> WE KNOW WHO THEY ARE.
>> Tucker: WHO THEY ARE?
>> WE'VE BEEN FOLLOWING THEM FOR
25 DAYS.
WE KNOW WHO THEY ARE.
THAT'S WHY WE KNOW THEY ARE NOT
CRIMINALS AND TERRORISTS AND